it's most about teaching in person
is eating the kids next
so y'all didn't know that y'all didn't
know the teachers we eat the kids back
that's why they never get by their lunch
boxes because we hired them done
and i love that one that y'all sent one
of the parents you guys send those
lunchables
oh those are oh those are great listen
you take a lunchable and you pair it
with a nice gas station wine
[Music]
that thing become a charcuterie boy
no she didn't that com becomes a
charcuterie boy okay vegas everyone has
gained an angel i'm reading from for my
notes here okay so bear with me comedian
angel gaines is set to perform at the
world famous comedy seller at the rio
through sunday and she's here to tell us
what she's bringing to the stage and i
have to apologize on behalf of all of
las vegas now we don't have any snacks
for you i know i don't have any luck for
you i was like that's the first thing i
was like oh let's see what they got
yeah i know i know now before we get
into the show i wanted to i wanted to
talk to you about um a new endeavor okay
on the table for you right yes so
tomorrow you're doing something special
so guess what i found out that they're
looking for a female emcee for magic
mike and i was like ah that's me that's
me
so i'm excited i've been rehearsing you
know like hey ladies let's get it
you know because as a teacher i feel
like i can relate you know and and you
know get women empowered and geeked out
because we're already in vegas you know
and we have that energy and that synergy
so we'll see i'm going to send in a self
tape girl oh my gosh i'm sorry you have
to keep us posted on that i will i will
i want you on stage with the magic mic
guys that show is so much fun okay now
to business okay let's talk about your
show at the comedy seller yes now it
started earlier this week yes and it's
going through sunday how's it been so
far so far so good i want to invite
everyone out we are doing a show at 7 00
and at 9 30. and it's been so much fun i
go on first so don't be late because
it's okay style it's showcase style
there yeah that's the seller right okay
there's about five or six performers yes
yeah you're first i mean yeah that says
something
i mean yeah
and it's been so much fun and i love uh
entertaining everyone from all over
they're so excited to be in vegas and um
my excitement you know matches theirs
because you know i love being here too
so yeah it's been really great so far
and what about just overall your your
journey in a nutshell can you just tell
everybody where you started and how you
got to make it to the vegas stage
yes in about one minute yeah so really
quickly i actually wanted to be a singer
so badly okay but i was so insecure and
so afraid that i pulled myself out of
the talent show and said introduce me as
a comedian because back in the 90s they
would boo you right yeah so you get like
apollo stage
i was like so i didn't quit i just got
booed but the emcee goes no booing we're
gonna respect her give her a chance i
was like oh my god i have no act nothing
to say i just got up there was just
crickets
but something happened that moment where
that comedian inside me that was really
there came out and then here we are oh
my god that's beautiful that's such
great encouragement for women out there
you know if even if you're a teacher
like you were a teacher back in l.a to
now you can always reinvent and find
everything inside you right absolutely
there are no limits we are limitless
exactly oh i love that okay so now angel
where do you gain your inspiration um on
stage for your jokes
so for me i like to really talk about
what i really feel and what i've
experienced because first of all that's
how i remember it
because i can't just make it up i'll
forget but i love you know i've been a
teacher for 20 plus years so i draw a
lot of my material from teaching and the
experiences with families and so you
know i just get inspiration from what i
do on a daily basis oh my gosh well i'm
so excited for you this is again keep us
posted on the magic mic but see her at
the comedy cellar at the rio through
sunday